(chill beat)
- Welcome to the Think Marketing Show,
the number one podcast for growing
and scaling your business
with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell.
And we're from Think Media.
And if this is your first
time listening, welcome.
- This show's dedicated
to helping you learn
how to get your content noticed
and the latest money-making strategies
working right now online.
So whether you want to
grow your YouTube channel
or maximize online video
across social media,
this is for you.
So we are talking about
all of the questions
that come into Think Media
and we want to address some of the ones
for business owners specifically.
And this one is critical.
We want to know what are three videos
every business owner needs?
- Yeah, this is great.
Number one, FAQs in video form.
And so this should be relatively easy
for every business owner
and leader watching.
What are the frequently asked questions
that come into your business?
And hopefully you already
have those on your website.
At the bottom of all of our
web classes we have FAQs.
At the bottom of all of
our products that we sell
we have FAQs.
And so you can take those
frequently asked questions
and turn them into videos.
It could just be you talking head.
Maybe it's just you,
you grab your phone you chat into.
Hey, people ask all the time about this.
And you then upload that on YouTube.
Because YouTube is a search engine
and because it has search engine value,
SEO, search engine optimization,
value to your business,
you want to be taking one question,
turning it into one video,
and then posting those on YouTube.
When you don't know
what content to create,
at least create those FAQ videos.
- Yeah, so those are
questions about other people.
Who about a video about them?
- Yeah, then the next
video you want to make
is an About Us video,
or an About Our Business video.
But where a lot of people mess up here
is that About Us video
should actually be about your customer.
Here's what I mean.
We want to recommend a book
called "Building Your Story Brand"
or "Building A Story Brand",
we'll link to that in
the description below,
by Donald Miller.
And basically it introduced
this revolutionary concept
that a lot of times when
we'd want to shoot a video
it would start out and be like,
hey, I'm Sean Cannell.
I founded Clear Vision Media back in 2010
after my father handed me the keys
and from generations before.
And you're already,
you're just talking about yourself.
And even your About Us page
on your website might be,
our company started back,
where what the book
"Story Brand" was teaching
was actually when you're
marketing your business
you need to understand,
kind of "Star Wars" is an analogy,
the hero in the story is
not you or your business.
The hero is your customer.
And your customer is Luke Skywalker
who needs to figure out how
to destroy the Death Star,
and you are Obi Wan Kenobi or you're Yoda.
Help you I will.
Was that (mumbles)?
You're Yoda trying to help your customer
accomplish their dream and their mission.
So even your About Us video
or About Our Business video
should be about how you can get
them from point A to point B
while weaving your story
into the whole process.
Therefore, if you think about it,
it's a ethical sneak attack.
It's the fact that you want
to point out the fact of
they are the hero of the story.
Articulate their biggest pain
point problem or challenge
so they know they're in the right place,
and then simply frame you and your,
you might then say, if you've
articulated that problem,
for the past 30 years,
we've been helping people like you
accomplish this mission.
And so through our company,
and now you're essentially
positioning them
as the hero of the story.
But then that's how your About
Us video could be framed.
And actually check out that book.
I mean grab the audio book
or grab the physical book
because that will reframe your mind
and make an About Us video
according to that framework.
- In celebration of the launch
of this brand new podcast,
we're giving away two tickets
to our annual conference
Grow With Video Live.
A $1,500 value.
- All you have to do to enter
is make sure you subscribe,
leave us a review on Apple Podcast,
and then take a screenshot of your review
and go to ThinkMarketingShow.com
for the rest of the details.
- So the third video
that every business owner
needs to make is what?
- Yeah, so I wrote this down.
Valuable content that solves
your target audience's problem
and gets them results,
momentum, or knowledge for free.
That is the essence of winning
online in 2020 and beyond.
If you want crush it in business online,
you should be posting,
I'm gonna say it again,
valuable content,
so the video should be truly valuable.
They're not wasting people's time,
it's not just fluff.
Sometimes you felt those old infomercials.
Hello,
welcome to this video about a video.
For the next 30 seconds
I will give you pointless information
that will lead to nothing productive
with a 60 second intro that also will lead
to just wasting your time,
which you have very
little of in this decade.
Now I will introduce some information
that you don't even care about.
And I will then bother you,
by this time, and this
we see a lot of videos,
you're like "This is
boring, it's irrelevant."
Valuable content,
so content the end user
truly finds valuable.
Well, what does it do?
It should actually solve
their current problem,
and here's a big one,
get them results in advance.
We've mentioned in
a couple past episodes of
the Think Marketing Show
about Roger Wakefield, the expert plumber,
who has a plumbing company,
who does solve plumbing
problems for customers,
but he's actually giving away information
that at times is making
people not hire him.
He's like "Look,
"if they can fix their toilet for $10
"with a little piece at Lowe's
or Home Depot without me,
"I'm actually just gonna
give them that information."
What that is leading to,
see as business owners we'd be afraid.
Aw, that's gonna put us out of business.
Now, it's giving him ore
business than he can handle.
He's giving away valuable content
that's solving their problems
and getting them results in advance.
So now he fired his marketing company
and his phone's ringing
off the hook more than ever
and he's creating even
additional income streams
because of following this model.
You want to be giving out YouTube videos,
Instagram videos,
snippets of LinkedIn
content in video format
or other formats that's
getting people results,
getting them momentum.
Maybe it just gets them
moving a little bit.
Maybe your whole customer journey,
how your physical product,
your digital product, your coaching,
it might take them a whole
journey to really help them
get to point A to point
B all the way to point Z.
But if it gets them momentum,
people love getting momentum.
If you do fitness or health,
people love getting that meal plan
and filling that shipping cart
with those first healthy foods.
Now they don't even know how to cook them,
but they got them home and they're like
"At least I got a little momentum."
Or knowledge, or just knowledge.
Wow, I just learned the
five biggest mistakes,
that a good video for your business.
The five biggest mistakes people make
when starting what you do,
or when needing help
with the thing you solve.
They're like "Wait,
"I'm just glad didn't
make those mistakes."
Knowledge that they start saying,
when I think about when I
turn on a YouTube channel
I'm about to spend money on tech.
I spend a lot of money on
tech, right, on Think Media.
Companies send us tech
and then I spend even more
money buying more tech.
'Cause we want to help people.
We're curious about what
really are the best products.
And so when I watch blogs
or when I read blogs
or watch videos or look at posts that say
"Oh, no, you don't want that one.
"because man, it really messes up here,"
that knowledge creates an affinity
with the person that created the content.
I go man that was so,
they just saved me $500.
They just saved me a week of my time.
Because I didn't even realize
that feature or that aspect
of what I was about to spend
my hard-earned money on
was not what I thought it would be.
Thank you,
for not only me,
I could return the product
but now I got to box it up.
You know what I mean?
Not only did I open it and I
learned it was the wrong thing.
So save people time,
save people money,
give people more peace of mind,
help create momentum for them,
get results in their lives,
give them knowledge that's
truly valuable for free.
Now when you start doing that,
that will unlock a world of possibilities
for growing your business
and your brand faster
with the internet and social media.
- So powerful.
Now if you're a business owner,
go make those videos.
We want to encourage you right now,
get a plan, have a strategy,
and make sure you have these
videos in 2020 and beyond.
And Sean, what are some other ways
if they want to go deeper with Think Media
and Think Marketing that they can do that?
- Yeah, I mean I think that
probably one really great way
would be to check out our video
about how to come up with the
exact content ideas and titles
for YouTube videos
so you know exactly
what problems to solve.
And so we'll link that on the YouTube card
and put in the description below.
We have three tips on our
process for how we do that
and that's how we've got over one point,
over 100 million video views,
was basically following
that system that we teach
on that free YouTube video
so you can go check it out.
And then I think that Growth video,
we're super excited.
Once a year,
business owners, business
leaders, influencers,
and people that,
coaches and experts, authors,
people in the nonprofit
space gather in Las Vegas.
People that want to learn video.
That's why our conference is
called Grow With Video Live.
And so if people want to
learn more about that,
GrowWithVideoLive.com,
2020's gonna be amazing,
and that's just a great way
to stay on the cutting edge
of how to build your business
with modern marketing, online video,
and the best digital marketing strategies
that are working right now.
- Thanks for checking out this episode.
We hope you got a ton of value.
And if you haven't already,
subscribe here to the Think Marketing Show
wherever you're watching or listening.
- And hey, it would mean the world to us
if you would rate and review
this show on Apple Podcast.
- As we grow this movement
of purpose-driven content creators,
we encourage you to share it with a friend
and we'll see you in the next episode.
(chill beat)